the new trailer for star wars the book
of boba fett looks absolutely stunning
the production quality looks very
similar to that of the mandalorian which
was fantastic and i can't wait to see
more of the backstory of the legendary
bounty hunter boba fett
everyone seems to be talking about the
trailer but they're all missing one
super important detail which could make
a drastic impact on the series and on
the star wars galaxy
welcome back everyone to stream in the
galaxy my name is rocket reilly and
today we're going to be talking about
the biggest detail everyone missed in
the new trailer for the book of boba
fett and the implications this will have
on the series but before we get started
if you're new to the channel please hit
the subscribe button and click the bell
icon to be notified when we upload a new
video
now in one of the trailer scenes we see
a wide view of a sunken city which may
be located on the planet of tatooine
since it seems like most of the series
story will take place on this planet
boba fett the show's main character has
a long past with a strong association to
tatooine and he'll be taking over the
throne of jabba the hutt whose palace
was located on tatooine this city
however is unlike any of the other we've
seen on the planet most of what we have
seen includes desert towns such as mos
eisley or sandstone-like structures such
as jabba's palace
this skyline though is much different
than what we've seen before potentially
showing an underworld to tattooing that
we have yet to see
in this scene we also see a ship flying
above the city and it has a very uncanny
resemblance to a ship we have seen
before
the razor crest
now i know what you're probably thinking
the razor crest was destroyed in the
second season of the mandalorian how
could it show up seemingly months after
its complete destruction
well i have several theories as to how
this could be possible the first being
that the mandalorian dinjarin repaired
his beloved ship after the events of the
second season of the mandalorian he had
such a strong attachment to the razor
crest that the audience started to gain
that attachment as well all within less
than two seasons of a tv show
after a raid by some jawas in the first
season we saw mando fix the ship from an
almost complete state of disrepair along
with the help of queel so we know he's
willing to go to great lengths to ride
his ship
also after developing an even further
attachment to the ship during his
adventures with grosgu i think he'd be
willing to go to even greater lengths to
make his ship whole again
there's also several fans who've
theorized that mando helped in the final
battle in the rise of skywalker after
noticing that a certain ship in the film
looks quite similar to the razer crest
lucasfilm digital content manager matt
martin even noted that the ship sure
looks like the razer crest so mando
could have repaired the ship and joined
the resistance fighters after all
however after seeing the crater left
behind in the razor crest's place on
tython i don't think it's very likely
that it could be repaired at all
so that brings us to theory number two
during his time living in exile
potentially with the tuscan raiders i
believe that boba fett heard word about
another mandalorian on tatooine
after hearing this he started a search
for mando for clues as to where his
armor may be although at the time it was
with the notorious cobb vanth
i believe this shot of what looks like
the razor crest is simply a flashback to
a time when boba was close to finding
mando before their initial meeting on
tython in season 2 of the mandalorian if
this is the case then we can expect to
see several different flashbacks
throughout the duration of the book of
boba fett series
i'm very much looking forward to seeing
how boba fett one of my favorite
all-time star wars characters was able
to survive the sarlacc pit as well as if
the razer crest was able to survive well
this
because the book of boba fett was first
introduced to us in the mandalorian i
think it's very likely that the two
shows will be highly interconnected
along with the upcoming live-action
series ahsoka the book of boba fett
seems to be somewhat of a spiritual
successor to the mandalorian continuing
the story of a post-empire galaxy from a
different character's perspective
this along with the fact that both den
jaren and boba fett are of mandalorian
ancestry leads me to believe that we'll
be seeing the two on screen together
quite soon i mean who doesn't love a
good pulse rifle gaffy stick team up
we also have several loosens related to
the mandalorian people that need tied up
we need to know what happened to boca
tan after being given the dark saber and
how the warlike tradition driven people
reacted to this apparent abdication of
the mandalorian throne by denjarin when
he handed over the sole symbol of
mandalorian leadership in the darksaber
we also need to know if thrawn former
grand admiral of the galactic empire
will finally be introduced in live
action or cause any problems for the
mandalorians
lastly we still don't know what happened
to the cult like mandalorian group the
children of the watch or if this group
will continue to have an impact on the
book of boba fett or the other
live-action star wars television shows
to sum it all up the live action story
of the mandalorian people is far from
over
well that's going to be everything from
us today on the book of boba fett if you
enjoyed the video please hit the like
button and don't forget to subscribe for
more great content what are your
theories about the show will the razer
crest make a reappearance we'd like to
know what you think so drop your
thoughts in the comment section below
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching